well guys thanks for watching we had a
lot of fun and uh we'll see you next
time
tata
all right we're clear good show
everybody all right
nice work
oh hold on one sec uh
take this
yellow is ethan
yeah what's going on
are you here
so
you're saying
okay
what was that
uh that was someone from youtube
they just said that we are suspended for
a week and if we upload anything we will
be uh permanently banned what what yeah
what
they uh basically uh
i don't know uh keemstar keemstar was
snitched on me wait yeah it says that we
have a strike what the hell
and got us suspended for a week
what oh my god you gotta be kidding me
what the hell do we do with our time
oh
my god dude i'm so over it
i think we're gonna have to just
go outside
sun scary we gotta go outside guys we
have a literally a week we have to be
brave
okay buddy it is kind of sad
[Music]
oh my god is this grass is this what
they call grass
so
grassy
i remember when i was a kid i used to
blow and it makes a sound
wow
[Music]
there's a whole world out here for me to
explore oh the bushes
oh i haven't touched a bush in ages and
not like
female genitalia but like nature bush
ants
look how they
how they
walk
i've been an ant
i've been an ant all these years but now
i'm a man
i'm a human
i'm free
oh this podcast has been nothing but a
curse on my life
i'm free
i'm free
i don't have to worry about being
demonetized i don't have to worry about
youtube i don't have to worry about zach
clogging our toilets i don't need to
worry about dan yelling at me i don't
need to worry about getting canceled
i'm free
[Music]
do
[Music]
well
it's been a good run
[Music]
hello
ethan
yeah how you doing
what's up baby dude trisha and keemstar
just recorded a podcast well i'm i'm
retired now abe i
i can't go back to that life i'm packing
up ethan we need you the show's over
dude i'm done i'm out i'm out of the
game and trisha together on a podcast
was there too
face blanks
i'm going back i gotta get the crew
together
aren't you zach this out loud
i used to be
hey what sick
no
are we back
we're back baby
what do we do what are you doing that's
that's four dollars what are you doing i
earned that
four dollars what are you doing
[Music]
yeah dan
we need you
dan
dan dan the hater dan the hater is no
longer here i am dan the lover
yeah we got chippies
sausage
no no look this is keemstar in the pool
with his clothes on he has a hat and a
jersey on in the pool i mustn't hate
oh
yeah
we're back baby
[Music]
hello ian
thomas what are you guys doing here
i'm a wood guy now
beautiful bird in the wyoming wilderness
we're getting the crew back together
we're doing a podcast again we're back
we need you and i'm not podcast again
yeah we need the salaried employee yeah
it's very interesting that's a that's a
really interesting
why are there spiderman
oh i've been working on hollywood
boulevard it's actually not bad money
nice i want my four dollars back do you
want to get tape on your mouth like ian
guys
we're back
one week later
the boys are back in town
that was one long week away from the
podcast
[Music]
and i'll be honest
it wasn't an easy week either
um
keemstar got us
suspended
he knarked on us to mommy susan
[Music]
we'll get into all that
i guess what happened was i uh we were i
think i understand
at first i was like i just don't
understand these rules like what did i
do there was a part where we had um we
had a fake calling if you guys remember
where keemstar's 20 year old girlfriend
called in and we had a conversation that
maybe got a little too explicit
about uh
keemstar was having performance issues
and stuff and uh i guess that hit a
little too close to home
because keemstar reported us to mommy
susan yeah really cross the line
which we'll get into
um first of all let me thank our
sponsors we love you
please thank our sponsors are the best
they really were accommodating because
we got
we got memed on for a week and they were
able to move them around for us so that
was really nice thank you to curology
kraken policy genius meundies and
hellofresh
we love you
also a brief uh but important shout out
to ela klein who continues to crush it
we support eat love we stan hila
jerry garcia the legendary guitarist
vocalist from the grateful dead
we are collaborating with his
estate
to bring you
a jerry garcia teddy fresh collaboration
uh
that is beautiful
in every way
anyway you get the idea head on over to
teddyfresh.com check it out thank you
peace and love
all right
here's what happened
so we got suspended
and then suddenly
trisha paytas
my ex bestie
was collaborating with keemstar
i'll be honest with you guys when i saw
them that she followed him on twitter
and then keemstar was making a whole big
deal i was like
there's no way
it could be that she's just following
him to catch up on stuff like that's
that's innocent i was like there's no
way she's actually gonna go on the
podcast like that's that's beneath even
her
yeah she she followed keemstar a couple
hours after we were banned
so people were raising their eyebrows
like that's strange timing but i was
like honestly even with trisha and how
much like animosity there's been
there's i feel like this is beneath even
her
and um
sure enough man
uh what was it a few days ago
during our suspension
because of keemstar widely known that it
was keemstar that did it i mean he took
credit for it it's not even in dispute
keemstar posted this photo
of her at their podcast and then
keemstar grinning flipping me off and
trisha wearing a frenemy's hoodie what
the [ __ ] and i was like i was like dude
this is betrayal on a whole new level i
mean especially considering just how
much smack
trisha had talked about keemstar
like literally two days like two days
ago
so basically what this is to me
she is a was the name of that the famous
turncoat during the revolutionary
benedict bennett arnold yeah she's she
benedict arnold me big time
this is an unforgivable
traitorous act and i'm going to explain
in great detail why and i'm going to be
totally honest with you guys
part of me wanted to take the high road
on this and just ignore it uh but at the
same time i'm so sick of her
disrespecting me
and my family and causing [ __ ] and just
being so toxic lying and i'm just so
freaking over her
um that i am just i'm over it
she's not she
she
look how happy she is to be there i look
how happy keemstar is to be to have her
there
yeah we're gonna get into all the
details but at this point i'm just like
okay trisha you went all the way low as
possible you collaborated with keemstar
after he suspended me you literally went
out of your way and followed him after
he suspended me and took credit for it
and so
all right if that's how you want to do
it then then that's it and i'm just
going to tell you i'm going to say at my
piece right now i'm going to talk about
i'm going to lay it all on the table
about this [ __ ] and i'm going to move on
with my life
i am just i'm not dealing with trisha
anymore that's it
i was close to privating every episode
of families over the weekend i'm not
even going to lie
for enemies you mean oh my god i keep
yes yes yes what the [ __ ] i was so close
to privating all the frenemies because i
was like
i'm still paying her i just sent her
like a huge amount of money
huge
and but i at the ultimate i was like you
know what
we do have some kind of verbal contract
so i don't and and also
people are just going to re-upload them
anyway so might as well
and by the way most of those episodes
just show
contradict all the lies she says about
me so why should i do her the favor of
removing them but that's how much i
actually just don't want to associate
with her anymore
and i'm just i'm over it dude i'm not
dealing with this [ __ ] anymore so i'm
gonna just gonna lay it all out there
and uh move on with my life and
literally by the way so let me take you
guys up from the top
all i said
in response to this ultimate betrayal
top anime betrayals of of the decade
can you think of a more iconic anime
betrayal than this
griffith with guts
i don't um i didn't get to that part
yeah oh [ __ ] oh wait no i did i did yeah
griffith and guts okay
this is more of a betrayal
all i said was that i'm not even gonna
front or try to be funny
this really just makes me sad that is my
simple
statement
which apparently was too much for even
her is just me
saying wow i'm sad
okay that's literally all i did
and so her response by the way to my one
tweet that's saying i'm sad she made 27
tick talks about me she made a 42 minute
video about me and 23 tweets about me
oh my god
saying i'm playing the victim i'm lying
i'm this and that i'm uh i i run a cult
and all my fans are harassing her it's
like girl all i said was that i was sad
did you really not expect me to be upset
about this
her total responses are tallied to 51
responses to my one tweet
and i'm the one that can't drop it
and come on let's not ignore the timing
of it i get suspended
keemstar takes credit for it
two hours later she follows them on
twitter
and they're plotting this podcast
so let's set the stage here let's not
let's not
let's not mince words she's clearly
doing this to
to uh
you know
to hurt me uh to hurt me
and it did hurt and i did you know
keemstar is obviously happy enough to be
to use her uh as a in his pawn here's
keemstar keeps her such a creep okay
so it just just to illustrate just kind
of what's going on here so as soon as i
tweet this i go oh wow uh this makes me
sad like wow this is my family right
and so just to show how happy trisha is
to be used by keemstar and his perverted
uh
his perverted little game of trying to
upset me w's i go this makes me sad
and keemstar goes w's and more w's
that's [ __ ] up like dude how perverted
and twisted like
is it a w that you're like
messing with my family
i guess
if you're really sick in the head
here's more my mom left a comment of
course my parents had to get into it
we're gonna get that we're posting
families this weekend we talk about it
so i'm just gonna wait
uh for that
my mom wanted to uh respond of course
so i'm gonna give her the opportunity
it's of course my mom said can't wait to
go to the wedding not i was like okay oh
jesus mom
of course my mom
look she's my mom she's being protective
i didn't know she was saying this i was
like driving in the car and i saw and i
was looking reading replies and i saw my
mom at the top and i was like oh my god
my mom's been on twitter for like a week
she doesn't know what she's doing she's
not use her tweets usually get zero
likes
also that seems like a very tame
response in terms of a mom
can't wait to go to her wedding not
yeah it's pretty funny i'll be honest
i mean i appreciate her defending me but
it's just she got to be careful when
making tweets
thank you shredder
ethan's mother now refusing to go to
trisha's wedding because she came on my
podcast the w is too big
so here's keemstar celebrating
an actual riff in my family because of
him doesn't that seem like
a bit much
to be celebrating like calling that a w
seems right on character for him i'm
busted it's kind of an expose on how how
much of a creep he is
dead ass feel bad for trisha now but at
least she knows that ethan and his
family never cared for they just used
her for content um
okay not sure how you drawing that
conclusion we definitely all cared about
her until she made 50 about 200 videos
about me calling me a liar
and like lying so you know he's happy
enough to use her okay
i'm just giving you guys a little
environmental of what i was dealing with
offline and unable to respond until now
and
keemstar says again why so sad
he's been blocked for like a year so i i
don't know what
why so sad yeah
he thinks he's the joker
here's the screenshot of trisha
that she followed him back two hours
after i got suspended
grab your popcorn we just getting
started keemstar and so she knows by the
way she knows
right
that keemstar is just doing this to piss
me off it's obvious based on this tweet
that he put out right after she followed
him so she cannot feign
ignorance like oh i'm just going there
to have a conversation no you're being
there to be a useful idiot to keemstar
to try to
cause problems in my family it's creepy
and weird
so
okay all i said was it made me sad now
at this point people are you know
finding trisha's interaction with kim
star uh questionable
and uh let's see trisha makes about a
billion videos uh trying to defend
herself talking about how she loves
conversation she's look she just free
speech dude conversation i marketplace
of ideas all of a sudden trisha is a
first amendment warrior who just wants
to enter the marketplace of ideas
like what where did this come from i've
literally never heard a talk like that
except the problem with trisha
is that she keep can't keep track of her
own [ __ ]
okay
here she is just like um
not that long ago in frenemies here's
what she said about keemstar
so you've got marketplace of ideas
trisha i'm just here for have a
conversation here's trisha a few months
ago
reacting to keemstar and quite frankly i
do not believe the alleged flick victim
and i don't want to even be a lot on
youtube like i will never say about any
channel except for this
like you know what i mean i don't think
any other channel should be banned off
youtube except for literally keemstar
what
she wants to d platform keemstar because
he said he doesn't believe
jake paul's accuser
damn it's crazy how she just she
completely
uh just changed completely
but here here she is one week ago saying
one week ago
what it's like okay that was a few
months people could change this was one
week ago on her show talking about
keemstar
and then they always will have like
ethan's back like the idea of even going
on like drama where i was just like yeah
because like like regardless like we're
gonna have to see each other right like
have a wedding coming up like i hope
they come home like that like we have to
see each other eventually so i'm not
trying to like
also
drama or trash like i'm not that bad
like keemstar called me irrelevant like
i'm not that bothered with a girl yeah
like i'm not that irrelevant yeah like i
guess she hit the bottom of the barrel i
guess she is that irrelevant happened in
the course of a week
she's kind of dissing herself in the
most severe way possible right now
we need to cut that up zach and have her
going i am irrelevant i am bottom of the
barrel you got it thank you it come to
me when i'm like in a cardboard box but
even then i probably wouldn't go on
drunk i'd rather just do it my cardboard
box like chill piece whatever
okay time to move into that cardboard
box trisha
i mean what a hypocrite what uh what a
what a immoral
she has no beliefs in anything
you know
when did her opinion change
somewhere between one week ago and when
keemstar got her channel suspended and
she could tap dance on my grave with
keemstar when did that change
and then the ultimate irony of course is
that i jokingly predicted this exact
thing to happen on episode three of
frenemies listen to this
dude i hated you dying like driving
jesus
sorry
i fricked up here guys
let's try that one more time dude i
hated you huh you're such like a judas
how you flip-flop between camps i'm sure
you'll be friends with keemstar in a
month from now absolutely being like
yeah ethan's [ __ ] our head used to go
to his house and you'll make start
making up [ __ ] like
yep judas
there's no such thing as a coincidence
there's really not
in the wake up so anyway of course
trisha wants to de-platform keemstar she
thinks he's the worst
and keemstar also at this time posted
this video of them
um
a little backstage clip of course kim
starts just playing her like for for the
you know for a fool just upon in his
dumb game his weird game
um
so he posted this clip of them all
laughing and having a good time
[Music]
i guess everyone looks heavier on him
he lost weight he's had his little fat
boy stages i go through them too but
like he's skinny right now yeah you know
what i did i did keto for a while and
lost it gradually which was good i'm
glad i did that but like recently i've
just been like raging and just eating
like once a day and yeah because you're
happier in a new relationship yes yeah
right there look at it oh
dude there's so much to unpack in this
clip
okay why do you think keemstar posted
this clip to tease the podcast do you
guys want to take any guesses is it be
is it could it be because um
moses is on the couch and he wanted to
rock the boat that way
is it is it because his 20 year old
girlfriend that trisha just ripped into
him a week ago is sitting right there
next to moses and everyone's just
happy-go-lucky and trish literally says
how did this story get blown out of
proportion girl what
what
how did this story get so blown out of
proportion
backtrack one week ago okay
from her
enemies podcast
whatever the [ __ ] that is
by the way trisha if you're gonna
complain about my production quality you
better get your ass you better like if
you're gonna make a podcast called
enemies you better [ __ ] like
get the editor get the producer get the
sound guy that you said that we needed
that was so professional like what the
[ __ ] she canceled the show because our
production quality wasn't up to her
stanzas and she's sitting in an empty
room echoey as [ __ ] totally unedited
it's dog [ __ ] i mean the quality is dog
[ __ ] i'm not i'm not
making a value judgment on what she's
saying
i'm just saying if you're going to quit
the show because the production is not
up to your quality you better [ __ ]
step it up
this is [ __ ] dude
5
100
here she is talking about
okay
trisha says
how did this get so blown out of
proportion
one week ago
then you're an actual creep in real life
like you are actually a real life perv a
real life
um
just creep just evil just nasty just a
nasty old man that's like hurting this
girl
in ways that she may not know and and
but you know you know guys
what do i say about this
let me say it
speak for itself
she said how's it get pulling out
proportion you
well it wasn't really blown out of
proportion it was a good story but like
i mean
you know ironically i probably wouldn't
have even
made that video without this because i
think that's how we found out about it
the name of the episode that we got
banned for was trisha versus keemstar
right
and it was because of the back and forth
between them
god how did you get so blown out of
proportion
but she's like there's nothing wrong
with that relationship
now that i see you and i'm too cowardly
to call you out for it
i love it i love it
you've
cowered
spineless
she is so spineless
just sit there in front of keemstar and
his girlfriend and act like how did this
get blown up abortion oh my god
how are you real
okay so let's let's let's take a big
step back here
so so trisha goes
this is the marketplace of ideas guys we
just sit and we have a podcast
okay
so keem so you know okay so let me set
the stage here
gabby hannah
defended this guy curtis
uh i forget his last name he r-worded
this girl jessie i forget the last names
but it was a big story and trisha was
like gabby
uh lapor was the curtis guy and what
jesse what
smiles
so
uh this is all very recent by the way
this isn't like years ago this is from
june 8th okay that's like a few months
ago
and and what was one of trish's most
unhinged videos of all time
look at that shot bro
that's not that's laying on a kitchen
floor that's not even sitting
she's straight up her old body's on the
floor
the lower she gets to the ground the
more unhinged the video is
okay so listen to what she says about
gabby
who she accuses of being an r-word
apologist
and let's just remember the context here
keemstar said
defends curtis and said way worse thing
so she's conveniently forgetting about
this but let's not get ahead of
ourselves let's watch
also this message is grabbing hannah
gabby hannah you still suck
you are a scariest [ __ ] and you are a
rape apologist those phone calls prove
that you are an actual apologist which
you denied deny denied and you are the
lowest most disgusting form of human
being ever and don't think for a second
that that last front of these episode
views had anything to do with you in
fact i'd rather them change your title
i'll ask them not to change the title to
storms out please change the title to
storms out because that's why people are
watching that and not you gabby no one
gives a [ __ ] i'm so sick that i even
talked about you that i have allowed you
to just absolutely eat and away at me
but now also jesse and all these other
people that you've been an absolutely
disgusting vile person too you are
disgusting you are a liar and a
psychopath and you need serious serious
help so don't even think for a second
that you're trolling or winning or
anyone thinks you're relevant
so she has that much energy for a r word
apologist
but
keep the same energy because um
keemstar
on the same exact situation said way
worse things and if you care about jesse
smiles she
seemed to have been way more offended by
what keemstar said than gabby
i hate cases of our word says keemstar
in most cases only two people in the
world actually know what happened
everyone else has to guess the jesse
smiles and curtis story is so hard to
believe because they were boyfriend and
girlfriend
so keemstar's thesis which he's he's hit
on many times is that
you cannot r word your girlfriend
it's impossible
they're your property to do whatever you
want with
but the truth is none of us actually
know what happened so here's jesse the
girl that that uh you know trish is so
passionate about
protecting
you have handled this situation with
such poor taste
you're right you don't know what
happened but you sure felt like you did
all these years when you consistently
called me a liar mocked my accusations
sorry you hate all these r word cases by
the way it must be hard on you
and she included a screenshot of
keemstar saying sorry jesse smiles
tagged her on twitter only has 140
characters please don't accuse me of r
word he's making a joke out of it
basically accusing her of making false
you know allegations
this is just one specific example of
keemstar's uh continued
uh
history of of um
not believing victims and actually well
here he is you know jake paul was
accused of
of uh essay
again recent trisha knows all about this
we talked about it on frenemies and uh
here is what he said about that
how does that happen i just i like
what
wouldn't she have to open her mouth and
like participate in some way for that to
happen
like can't you just turn your head or
can't you just get like is is there is
there
is there some way to force oral sex
on someone i mean she said once again
keemstar
is saying that you cannot orally r word
someone because you can just turn your
head he's he's uh you know blaming the
victim calling her a liar
and you know all this so where's your
energy
for keemstar the r word apologist that
you have for gabby
it's entirely inconsistent
and you definitely know that keemstar
harassed eila for a year calling her a
horse tweeting pictures of horses at me
you definitely know how he harassed a
bee's wife during the same time tweeting
him pictures of witches saying his wife
looked like a witch
so which is it do you care about victims
or do you not because i honestly can't
tell
but maybe we're jumping to
conclusions because at this time all
this went down we hadn't even seen the
podcast yet it just showed all we saw
was that one clip that keemstar put out
shut up okay
i said you know what it shows like okay
let's wait and see the podcast
here she says
she says everybody's jumping to
conclusions you haven't even seen the
podcast yet here she is trisha i'm not
reading the comments online because like
the internet is just literally so stupid
on so many levels like it is stupid at
the end it is stupid but i won i take
pride in not cowering away from people i
have disagreements with people that
don't like me like i will always talk to
confront respectfully
people that i've issued with and i call
it out i don't know why people haven't
even heard the episode like this is
awful it's like you haven't even heard
it
like
i saw the hate comments going on i'm not
afraid i'm not afraid of backlash i'm
not
well anyway she's saying basically she's
saying you haven't even heard it i
defend ethan and i attack keemstar so
you guys are gonna be look like real
idiots when this podcast comes out
so
we are the two the pockets came out
and uh i watched it all
okay
it was by the way 30 minutes
it was a 30 freaking minute podcast
like
trisha was so happy to be used by them
for 30 minutes like they couldn't even
they go sorry trisha 30 minutes is up
our producer has to go how do you
your producer has to go after 30 minutes
did you guys not plan this at all
pretty amazing
anyway so i watched the i watched the
podcast let me let me give you a
synopsis you can watch plenty of cuts of
it online
um it was basically 30 minutes of of uh
them both [ __ ] on me non-stop
and did trisha challenge keemstar on
it was 38 minutes thank you a.b
did trisha challenge keemstar on dating
the 20 year old girlfriend
no
did she challenge him on being an r word
apologist no
did she challenge him on saying mental
health health
illnesses don't exist and people just do
it for attention no she did not did she
challenge keemstar bowling people and
using them for entertainment up until
the point that they break or even
unalive themselves she did not even
mention any of those points did she
challenge him on getting my channel
suspended no
did she challenge him on falsely
accusing people of being a p word and
ruining people's lives
she did not
what you'll find in the podcast is i'm
circle jerking about what a piece of
[ __ ] i am for 30 minutes just take it
from keemstar himself who did the no
jumper podcast like the next day
and listen to how keemstar described it
did so when you the episode isn't out
yet do we know when it's coming out it's
coming out tonight at midnight eastern i
asked for the advanced copy said spotify
would never let it happen oh that's what
you said yeah yeah yeah they won't give
me an idea of something he's talking
about dip [ __ ] just send him an audio
file what the [ __ ] you talking about
spotify they probably pay him like 10 a
month for that dog [ __ ] podcast 30
minutes their episodes are so short like
dude oh my god bro
[Music]
the fact that spotify pays these goons
to make a podcast will
endlessly blow my mind
the episode will already be out by the
time this episode's out even though
we're going to rush it but what was
discussed we talked about so many topics
and like which is bang bang all over the
place
and we ended up
bashing ethan a lot
them firsthand ethan and banks have had
beef trisha and ethan have had beef
obviously me and ethan have beef and so
that was the one
bro can i like what are you doing with
your life keemstar look at those glasses
that he wears that he wears a keemstar
necklace a faze hat
and ski glasses
in summer in la he's walking around in
ski glasses can you be more of a tool
not to mention the
full uh jersey and hat in the pool we'll
get to that okay we'll get to that trust
me that's my favorite thing i've ever
seen we're getting to all that i have
been caught in 4k
common thing that kind of connected all
of us
is you know
us criticizing ethan so there you go you
know we have a lot in common we all hate
ethan
so what exactly was i waiting for trisha
i watched the whole thing
what was i waiting for to see
i have like a mega cut here
of them talking [ __ ] about me but i
don't even know if it's if it's
if it's if i do i should i show this do
it
if the thing is the mega cut doesn't do
justice to how much they were just
non-stop talking [ __ ] about me but this
is three minutes pay you he would never
do that
he's never in a million why because
ethan's a [ __ ]
he really is she really is trish
tricia ethan will not put himself in a
situation where he knows he's going to
lose all right this is why the last
podcast of frenemies like never aired
right yeah
so in that way i think she has the ethan
syndrome a little where it's like if you
can't mention one fault that you did she
says now it's the ethan syndrome gabby
has the ethan syndrome bro let's [ __ ]
go
that's a terrible syndrome you don't
want to get diagnosed with that but now
i'm the original
it's cabbie has the ethan syndrome right
yeah not ethan has the gabby syndrome
i think i've ever seen her one time be
like you know what i was wrong
and that's where i'm at with ether right
now the fact that he can't admit that he
did something wrong like publicly and
i'm still getting all this hate about it
it's like annoying yeah i'm sure
nobody's hating on you for going on
keemstar's podcast being a total tool
hypocrite
you've basically spent like the better
part of the last two years talking about
how what a piece of [ __ ] game stars and
how he should beat the platform and now
all of a sudden when you have an
opportunity to
dan tap dance on my grave with him you
take it with and within two hours of
being suspended you it's like bruh
you're such a traitor
didn't come back and like it sucks
because i really did like front of me
like i was down to go the next day to
film he's like will you film tomorrow
after a big fight i was like yeah and
then that's when he told me like the
crew wasn't comfortable and then that's
when i lost my [ __ ] because i was like
he's screenshotting my [ __ ] i mentioned
it to my youtube rep i'm like can you do
this stuff on on youtube
and he's like no i don't think so here
he is so then it got age restricted so
here he is admitting to getting our
keemstar puppet sketch
age restricted by the way
okay well something further so that's
true i technically did flag because i
made a twitter video tagging ceo
reported that i didn't do it through
youtube no
weird so well that's also why i was like
let me just talk to him so you don't
play me because it is i would never i
want a bully i want to harass i want to
[ __ ] talk [ __ ] i do toxic man i want
to roast this guy but i can't cause
youtube won't let me but he could say i
got a little dick [ __ ] puppets like what
is this by the way keemstar is lying he
can say whatever he wants about me he
just can't stand the [ __ ] heat he
tried to ruin my life as many times as
possible it didn't work and now he's got
nothing to say about me so we [ __ ] on
him all we want he can't see anything so
now he's crying oh youtube doesn't let
me talk about him you're a [ __ ] liar
because guess what i'm still sitting
here calling you a piece of [ __ ]
that you are a horrible person and i'm
never going to stop calling you out
because youtube didn't is never told me
don't talk about keemstar i mean you're
lying
you just can't stand the heat bro you
can't stand that i have a little puppet
about you
where's the puppet grab the puppet
right and i think that is like the
hypocrisy of ethan i'm not gonna [ __ ]
the puppet i would never i'm not doing
that i've changed i've reformed good
that was wrong it's big of you to admit
that you were i was wrong i shouldn't
have [ __ ] the puppet that clearly
upset keemstar yeah
it was too far enough to complain to
youtube about it yep it was too far i
should have [ __ ] the puppet yeah
that said we believe thank you a.b that
everybody deserves a platform and free
speech here at the h3 podcast unlike
some people on the internet i know it's
my even though it's my constitutional
right to be able to [ __ ] this puppet
youtube doesn't like it so this is a
puppet of keemstar he goes ethan you are
a [ __ ] hypocrite which is all he
basically says
and keemstar did you get my um
it's interesting you just admit to
getting my
my sketch with the puppet age restricted
was that you yes it was me but i didn't
click the
i didn't click the uh report a flag so
you know it real it wasn't me but yes i
did write them and complained about them
several times okay so it does sound like
it was you yes yes it was me
okay
and keemstar
were you responsible for me getting
suspended for a week i didn't click the
flag button but yes i did tag team
youtube and susan waginski the ceo of
youtube and i also admitted on video
that i've been writing youtube uh every
time you mention me and crying behind
the scenes
okay so it was you yes okay
all right here's what's in what
what's interesting about the chemo maybe
it takes you to take the puppy does that
take
quite a dome look at that take the
puppet all right take it all right team
starts crying to youtube as we speak we
gotta go to break
all right let's go to break we'll be
right back we got plenty more to talk
about
thank you to
curology i used to think my skin goals
were unattainable and since i started
curology i honestly feel like my skin is
glowing whether you're trying to take
control of your acne or acne is no
longer your top skin concern but fine
lines dark spots occasional breakouts or
clogged pores gerology customizes a
prescription formula with three active
ingredients picked for you to tackle
your skin care needs how it works is
you answer questions you take pictures
of your skin and you send in the selfies
and the report to curology and next
curology matches you with a licensed
dermatologist provider who gets to know
your skin and if it's a good fit they're
going to customize a prescription cream
to address your acne your fine lines
your dark spots whatever you need
they're going to be able to tell based
on the questionnaire in the photos and
they're going to get that perfect
formula basically how mine has been
going is they sent me three products
they sent me the cleanser the formula by
the dermatology provider and the
moisturizer and the cleanser is super
soft it takes all the oil off my face
without making it feel dry i put on the
cream from the dermatology provider and
then i moisturize and i feel great i
really do feel like my skin is glowing
more than ever curology sets you up with
a personalized treatment plan and ships
the custom formula right to your door
i really recommend it i've been enjoying
it a lot it's time to take control of
your acne dark spots breakouts or
whatever your new unique concerns may be
with a powerful skincare treatment made
for you today go to curology.com
h3 for a free 30-day trial just pay for
shipping and handling that's
c-u-r-o-l-o-g-y
dot com slash h3 to unlock your free
30-day trial see cureology.com for all
the details
thank you to kraken uh crypto exchange
for sponsoring us today uh owned of
course uh friend of the show jesse
powell
love this man he's a good man he's
supporting the show
and uh kraken is a great exchange i
can't recommend it enough for the last
10 years kraken has been one of the best
platforms for trading crypto online now
with the new [ __ ] kraken app it's easier
than ever to buy and sell over 60 of the
most popular cryptocurrencies on the go
simply download the kraken app connect
your bank account and start investing
for as little as ten dollars just takes
one minute to get started and with the
new app the new kraken app you'll have
your portfolio in your pocket wherever
you go you can monitor your investments
track your winners and losers keeps tabs
on your favorite projects or view the
most traded cryptocurrencies of the day
it's got all the features you need with
none of the complexity it's a simpler
way to invest and you get to support our
show if you're interested in crypto or
exchanges or whatever
please use kraken kraken dot com slash
h3 visit kraken.com hp to learn more or
search kraken and the app store thank
you kraken
things you want to do evening swimming
popsicles on a hot day rub a dog's belly
things you don't want to do overpay for
home and auto insurance policy genius
can help look for similar coverage to
what you have now but at a lower price
why use a policy genius well i'll tell
you right now makes it easy to compare
home and auto insurance in one place
they can also help you find home and
auto coverage
similar to what you have now but at a
lower price they've saved customers on
average 1 250 per year over what they
were paying for home and auto insurance
before the switch
they saved new customers on average 435
dollars per year on auto insurance they
say new customers on average 350 per
year on home insurance their team
handles all the paperwork they set you
up with the new policy and they switch
you over from your current one they
handle everything they find you the
better price and guess what it's all for
free too they don't charge you a
freaking penny getting started is easy
head on over to policygenius.com
after dark and answer a few quick
questions about yourself and your
property then policy genius takes it
from there they'll compare rates from
top insurers
from progressive to allstate to find the
lowest quotes possible
um
the policy genius team can look for ways
to save you more including bundling your
home and auto policies if you find a
better rate than what you're paying now
they'll switch you over for free their
top notch service has earned policy
genius thousands of five star reviews
across trustpilot and google so guys
head on over to policygenius.com
after dark to get started right now
that's policy genius when it comes to
insurance it's nice to get it right
look on this show we're all about
self-love and that's why you need to get
yourself some me undies
i know you got that tattered old
underwear that's all like uh it's all
like
peeling and there's tears in it i mean
how much underwear are you carrying
around from like the sixth grade it's
time to grow up
and treat yourself damn it
me undies it's soft it's breathable it's
unlike any underwear you've ever worn
and trust me once you go me undies
you're never going back the comfort does
not start with imagining but with a
feeling so once you get your jewels in
there boy let me tell you
you're going to be comfort
comforted to your core me undies are
designed to be the softest thing on the
freaking planet
um
you know me andy's got the signature
micro modal fabric that is literally
growing from trees making their me
undies not only super soft but also
sustainable they offer different cuts
because they get it we've all got
different buts
i got a fat one
check out their undies socks bralettes
loungewear and more and they're ranging
from sizes x
uh extra small to 4xl we love that
mandy's has a great offer for our
listeners for any first time purchase
you get 15 off and free shipping damn
meundies also has their problem free
philosophy if you're not satisfied with
any product for any reason they will
refund or exchange it no caveats no
questions
uh it's a it's a it's a no lose here
guys get 15 off on your first order free
shipping and 100 satisfaction guaranteed
go to meundies.com h3 that's
meundies.com
h3
with hello fresh you get fresh
pre-measured ingredients and
mouth-watering seasonal recipes
delivered right to your door skip the
trips to the grocery count on hellofresh
to make home cooking fun easy and
affordable that's why it's america's
number one kit meal let's be honest i
mean i think most people love to cook
but there's so much hassle surrounded by
you to go to the grocery store and then
it's like you got to buy the right
portion you know you ever buy celery i
mean that's just one thing you got to
buy like 10 celeries who uses that much
celery and that's kind of what's nice
about hello fresh is they send you the
portions so you have to buy these
ungodly amounts just to make one meal
fall is busy but hello fresh recipes are
gonna save you time when you'd otherwise
be spent meal planning shopping chopping
so you get back what matters time
and hellofresh's family friendly menu is
a big one for back to school season with
easy delicious recipes for drama free
dinners here's one example that we
cooked up recently the pizza
ian you made this one right
uh yeah we put it together uh it was
great it was uh super simple and uh
we had all the ingredients there didn't
have to worry about anything it was
delicious what is this a vegetable pizza
or what do you call this it's a
pineapple barbecue flatbread
wow that sounds bomb
yeah that was great is that asparagus on
it
i think it's a green cream peppers
daddy likes
guys if you want to get in on the action
of the thrill of having beautiful
home-cooked meals sent right to your
door
then go to
hellofresh.com h314
and use the code h314 for up to 14 meals
including free shipping come on
it's america's number one meal kit for a
reason guys so one more time go to
hellofresh.com h314 and use code hd14
for 14 free meals with free shipping
thank you thank you
all right we are back um
so i was watching uh the super cut here
of uh all the lovely things she said
i think it's like gross when people do
make fun of people's like looks or small
penises or whatever i don't like when
people make fun of people's aesthetic
okay fine i didn't say he had a small
penis i said
he had performance issues i wasn't that
specific about it
but oh did i say he had a little one
maybe i did who cares i think he did but
like who cares came is it really hitting
that close to home that you had to cry
to youtube about it and this snake
[ __ ] started getting hate
because i'm on there and you know i'm a
controversial figure so he leaves a
comment he goes listen i know some of
you guys hate keemstar don't worry we
hate him too
we just thought this would be
entertaining and i that that was a knife
in my back that's the biggest thing that
i dislike about ethan and just don't
appreciate about him is he's constantly
pandering to the audience he's constant
and now it's all tell that to our
audience
yeah i know i was like bro have you
read the comments
who am i pandering to exactly
blanks
my biggest criticism of faith blanks is
that he's friends with keemstar if i'm
being honest and that is a huge
criticism like somebody that could
actually sit across from keemstar and
validate him as a human being is
that's just that's like in that i mean
bro
you could be you could be mother teresa
apparently mother truth you could be
who's an undisputed great person i feel
like we're losing him day by day yeah
not mother teresa people she was able to
not like her yeah she actually was one
of the worst apparently
mlk
you could be mlk but if you if you're
friends with keem then you're ml uh
ml
l
for the l ml
l
m l k
m taking the l k yeah pretty much
more responsible with what you [ __ ]
say and sjw and all this [ __ ] and he's
done a full 180. and it's because that's
the audience that's like the mainstream
what mainstream people people want
i mean like people change i try my
hardest not to change right i try to
that's so admirable bro
that's what life is all about
wow keemstar says i try my hardest not
to change and interestingly um
well yeah about since the age of 15 he's
been true to uh that mantra
but uh unfortunately you know me being
an evolving human being
educating and bettering myself over the
years is uh something that of course
keemstar looks down on
team star right but even me like i have
to
i have to calm down and tame things down
because we get in trouble now we can't
do what we used to do back in the day
but ethan's change has been so drastic
like you haven't changed
and seems plastic he definitely goes
with what the audience says which is
like so that's the worst part i think
that's what the end of frenemies was
because he got so much hate from that
last episode because so it's so on i i
didn't get hated for the last episode
by the way what is that statement
i i always pushed through
through the controversy with you i mean
i don't know what you're talking about
about i mean i do think trisha is
i do think trisha is uh confessing and
uh projecting a little bit here
because
first of all i don't read i've kind of
disengaged from the comments from my
mental health like years ago and it's
one of the best things that i've ever
done
to have a sustainable career on youtube
and um
trisha reads everything i know that so
i think this is just projection and
confession here
first he's like yeah let's film tomorrow
let's do it and then all the comments
were like trisha's like spoiled entire
all this stuff like that and then he
like changed it i just think the amount
of effort i'll just use ethan is the
example the amount of effort he'll put
in and the length he's willing to go to
like
make an accusation or highlight a bad
part of somebody if he gets it wrong he
doesn't put an equal amount of effort in
redeeming it or correcting it i don't
know i don't get so much hate from his
audience like literally even not it's
not even that so my audience is your
audience too
trisha's got this weird thing where she
thinks that all the hate she's getting
is just h3 fans it's like
i think i hate to break it to you trisha
but i think they're mostly your fans
that are become disillusioned with you
i mean we would get like four or five
million views per podcast of frenemies
and we get like you know 2 million on a
really great episode here so
there's like 3 million extra people
there
that don't care about me
um
yeah i think most h3 fans just want this
to be over i think they're exhausted
from the drama and so am i okay peace
and love
and by the way we've said so many times
in ila who's the only time she's ever
commented on her bless her beautiful
gentle soul said do not harass moses do
not harass treasure their people you
know i'm i'm so like come on
there are that obviously those things
but like the stuff that he said saying i
wanted to have the whole crew fired i
hang on to that so much because i would
never say that's something i do and i'm
just like oh the fact that you don't
correct this i've reached out to ethan
twice on twitter to make peace because
our our beef is so [ __ ] deep right
that it's exhausting right and i wanted
to just stop it so many different
[ __ ] times he's not interested like
he wants me de-platformed
yeah
well it's like we don't i don't
negotiate with terrorists you know
there's a reason for that you know what
i mean it's like why would i sit across
from you and validate you as a human
being you are irredeemable scum you are
the worst person on this platform by far
and yes you've been he's had like four
channels that have all been banned he
should not have a platform on youtube
he's dangerous he's uh harmful he's just
he's just
yeah dude
you know
yes
apparently keemstar thinks i shouldn't
have a platform because as far as i'm
aware he's got one video age restricted
one he got me a a one week suspension
and i've done nothing to him
as far as crank to youtube goes [ __ ]
baby the difference being action where
you know you're saying you don't think
he deserves it but
there's no pub he deserves it but what
is that i go yeah he deserves it but
like what what is me saying he deserves
it dude i don't control policy where
he's publicly putting out videos tagging
the ceo of youtube and he goes mommy
yeah
yeah i mean
i
could predict that he would likely say
that the whole saga where he lost a
bunch of sponsors because of the videos
that you made would be his retort but
that really is different because
that
you just criticized him and then people
reacted right exactly
to youtube
by the way which keemstar has done his
whole career going after people's
sponsors sure so like okay dude whatever
the [ __ ] but that whole thing i was like
how is g fuel sponsoring this guy he's
got a can of g4 while he's like
slandering
falsely accusing people of being p wars
i just found it pretty ironic i wasn't
like go email g fuel if g field wants to
pull their sponsor from keemstar uh
because he's a piece of [ __ ] you know
that's probably a good idea on their
part his argument and the whole
situation boiled down to two things was
that you are for the platforming and
that you want people to uh lose sponsors
which both have been shown on his end
proven proven shout to comment cop and
on my on on my uh part not proof i mean
you could say that me bringing a notice
to what nobody cares i don't give a [ __ ]
keep saying you're so irrelevant to me
he thinks that we have this beef it's
like i just don't like you bro and i
[ __ ] on you every chance because
everyone else is like afraid of you for
good reasons because you're such a
psychopath and listen i've gone through
the pain of uh you trying to dig out
every skeleton in my closet and doing
the best you can and now i have like
this beautiful uh freedom to make to
just [ __ ] on you endlessly which i take
full advantage of
i mean i don't think about you more than
that bro
this is kim start time stamping right
now mommy susan
ethan said it was mean to me
i mean i i don't believe in deep
platforming and i believe in the first
uh constitutional right of free speech
but ethan said a mean thing about me
somebody please strike his channel
[Music]
you know my favorite thing about this
was keemstar went on this no jumper
podcast
and boy
the comments were gold
i know keemstar's feet are swinging off
that chair
he was up very look how high he cranked
that because i'm pretty sure adam is a
tall guy
like how tall is adam he's got to be
like six foot plus yeah he's over six
well he's really tall so keem is like
five three i think i i pointed that to
av yesterday i'm like he's gotta be on a
booster or something man i want a
drawing where it shows his feet like
ending like up here
i that's the comments head someone said
keem starts really acting like he didn't
meet his girl at a fan meet up yeah he's
he's revising history he met his 20 year
old girlfriend as a fan made up
uh keem really acting like he isn't
dating his daughter's babysitter
keem couldn't handle being the short guy
with that seat all the way up
i was really loving these comments way
to go adam you sunk even lower also it's
funny how keemstar makes fun of anyone's
appearance when he refuses to take his
hat off because he's bald the definition
of peak in high school
kim got that chair higher up than his
own height
[Laughter]
all i can say is from a 47 year old
woman he's absolutely right his brain
hasn't paid aged past 20. and and and he
admits that he says i try my best not to
change
keemstar and trisha judging anyone is
literally a joke trisha is a clown she
played into his game she didn't even go
after him for what she yelled about last
week just shows she doesn't care about
young girls and older men it's just so
she can she
it's just does she just does it so she
can bring up jason yep she doesn't care
at all it's totally performative she she
literally doesn't care if she did she
wouldn't go sit with keemstar and at the
very least she would actually bring it
up instead of saying how did it get
blown out of proportion like what
did anyone notice how keemstar changed
his story on how he met his girl
i haven't seen any of the videos yet but
i'm guessing this is going to be exactly
like the cold ones episode where
keemstar whines and cries and won't scfu
and i can't get past the 10-minute mark
yep
yeah the comments are amazing
yeah
it's awesome
he said he can't discredit trisha
because he's telling she's telling her
own story what about jesse's smiles good
question keemstar was quick to discredit
her
yeah
wait so his new story is that she was at
a party at his house
yeah yeah he's he's it's like bro if
you're how do we know that those aren't
how do we know that those are uh
fan meet up at a party at his house oh
brother please
i i seen the picture of the meet and
greet it looks like a public venue but
okay
this is a great comment the key the way
keem snitched on h3 was way more
effective than clicking report yeah of
course he's like oh you click the report
button it's like no you wrote youtube
and tag team youtube and
uh and susan wojcinski it's like okay
yeah you didn't click the report button
like okay dude
and hugely hypocritical considering he
had been conspiring about h3 snitching
with on him to youtube which i didn't do
there's no evidence
it's just keemstar spinning [ __ ] and
then keem goes on record
to record a video doing exactly what he
claimed h3 did i was always on keem's
side during this feud but i don't
support anyone who is down with the
platforming
douche
kim is literally obsessed with ethan he
brings him up everywhere he goes yeah
well does he have a puppet of me
checkmate if he does he does not he
probably you know does naughty things
that
youtube would suspend him for a week for
catch my drift team star [ __ ] anyway
enough of that
so where was i
yeah you thought i was playing around i
got like a whole dossier on this [ __ ]
i'm not even i'm like halfway through
i was like you know what i'm going if
i'm going in i'm going all the way in
so
let's see so this so going back to the
interview
when trisha said just wait and watch the
interview before you judge me
well
obviously here she is now simping
for keemstar
simping for keemstar who just a few
months ago said should be the platform
for being a r word apologist she doesn't
care about uh she doesn't care about
anything
he did the title and thumbnail about me
it got taken down which by the way i
asked him so i was like oh my god did
you get that taken down he's like no i
didn't i didn't hit the report like he
did a brand video about it like that
because to me that's scary no it wasn't
kim star he said he didn't hit the
report button oh
well i guess it's subtle due diligence
she had no problem taking keemstar's
side we love keemstar that's when it's
like crossing this line right now you're
trying to de-platform people and not
give people voices
but which things he even thinks he
believes in that people should be i
don't believe in that no matter what it
seemed it was important bro you
literally said i want to de-platform
keemstar you've said so many times you
want to do platform keemstar you want to
do platform jane you want to platform
david you're such a liar
you literally just changed your mind on
that just to make an excuse to go talk
to keemstar
such a liar
so inconsistent
holy [ __ ] why that keem striped ethan's
video
i lied about kim you swear like he told
me what happened bottom line ethan's
video got flagged it was all implied
that it was keem and i was i was a
little scared i was a little scared and
then that's why i'm like you know when
things go too far
when people lose sponsors when people
start you know threatening people's
channels taking them down you know like
it's super scary
and some people like the bees and back
and forth and if i'm being completely
honest i know keem loves it he's texting
me right like this is great i'm texting
him like this gives me anxiety that was
my favorite part where she goes oh yeah
i'm texting with keem now by the way he
loves it
judas that's
judas that's this man who one week ago
was the worst now we're texting he loves
it
he goes did you see what ethan's mom
said she's so upset i love it thank you
trisha
thank you for gifting me this
you're welcome kim star i forgive you
for everything i love it
wow dude
[Music]
um yeah i mean obviously if trisha cared
at all
keemstar it's obvious and he's admitted
to
getting or getting us suspended here
deaf noodles has got the receipts shout
out to deaf noodles
here
i had my own issue with keemstar i made
the first video towards key and star
ethan inserted himself in it
and his channel got banned
keem did not do the strike on his
channel that's [ __ ] there's plenty
of evidence that keemstar messaged
youtube about the video not only on
twitter but he literally said in a video
that he sent numerous emails to youtube
throughout the years tattling on ethan
susan uh team youtube everybody hold on
zach play the baby music
kim i'm so sorry mommy team star versus
h3h3 and youtube staff explain that to
me why is there blatant favoritism i
have the emails i have all the proof to
back it up i have sent emails when he
broke my cos saying hey look he's doing
the same thing that you threatened to
kick me out of the partnership program
the guy [ __ ] confessed in video he
tagged the youtube ceo he said it in the
video that he's been sending emails for
who knows thank you so much
by the way speaking of since we're on
the topic of death noodles he put out a
video today showing some dm's keemstar
sent him and they were so mind-blowingly
insane i mean i've got i've got messages
from him
like this my whole life
um but it's interesting
to see other people sharing let me find
this dm hang on here i'm just
[Music]
guess what folks dump he's terrified of
death
why is he so scared of death noodles he
wanted def to be his replacement at one
point he reached out to him and def
turned him down
and now i think he's just worried that
def is on the come up and he actually
well actually out def noodles is really
good like honestly he's he's got he's
super organized like he he gets
i don't know man he's i really actually
like his videos and he's he likes
dropped the stick recently yeah and uh
shout out to def dropping the shtick
good choice
family actually really enjoying his
videos for drawing really apologize this
[ __ ] is gonna blow your mind just watch
this this is a little bit of a side but
it's it's worth it there are some
insecure 40-year-old man having a
midlife crisis
literally months over dm's he doesn't
want anybody to have a piece of the pie
in fact keemstar is so out of his
[ __ ] mind when it comes to
competition folks that even though we
had spoken for literally months over dms
we have each other's phone numbers we
texted we even talked on the phone
several times one time for almost an
hour even though we had somewhat of an
acquaintance with each other the minute
that ethan klein and trisha paytas
started retweeting me he absolutely lost
his [ __ ] even though i had nowhere near
the same relationship that i had with
keemstar like i actually kind of knew
keemstar i had never even spoken to
ethan or trisha and he [ __ ] lost his
[ __ ] to the point where he dm'd me this
you have lost your [ __ ] way and
you have lost your [ __ ] mind
the day has come dennis and when it
comes i want you to know it was me what
no comment why are you working for ethan
and trisha i totally ignore those dm's
folks can you believe
that this guy is real i mean what i want
you to know it was me dude i just wanna
know how many times he rolled his eyes
while typing this
he's so sassy dude god he's so much sass
he's such a creep i mean he is such a
creep
and you know he's not kidding because he
said well you'll see he goes i'm sorry i
got heated like and the day is coming
and i want you know it was me you were
rude the day that you crossed me boy
okay dude
i try my best not to change like what
the [ __ ] am i supposed to do reassure
some insecure 40 year old man having a
midlife crisis in his home office
trembling because one guy is making
videos in the same segment as him
oh man was so [ __ ] pathetic anyway
the next day he did the emmy again and
not really apologizing but just kind of
acknowledging that he had a mental
breakdown
from that day on folks this [ __ ]
started attacking me constantly yeah so
um
he's so paranoid he thinks he goes why
are you working for trisha and ethan
like literally
don't no association we just where we
found him on twitter and he's on top of
all the gossip and stuff so it's really
useful and we we're like oh we like his
twitter account and then keemstar loses
his mind he gets all paranoid that we're
working together
and so basically if you guys would all
go subscribe to deaf noodles to make him
the premiere drama channel that would be
great
david please stand up apparently that's
keemstar's biggest fear in life is uh
this
man deaf noodles i gotta say death's
really become a household name
in like the uh in your household no no
no just like family watch is death no
i'm just saying he he's his relevance is
really skyrocketing yeah he's good i
mean he's great well keem [ __ ] talks him
every chance he can he was [ __ ] talking
about no jumper oh guess who guess who
got deaf noodle suspended on twitter
right i was about to bring that up that
that was the implication in that dm
right oh yeah when it happens know that
it was me
like
it's gotta be the twitter suspension
yeah well he definitely celebrated
either way even if he tries to deny it
he was celebrating it
the man who's against d platforming
yeah can we just dismiss that myth at
this point you know at the point the
point i'm kind of driving at is that
keemstar and trisha really deserve
themselves they have no um
consistency they believe in nothing but
themselves they'll say and do anything
to get the upper hand
uh they're total hypocrites i think you
know what i think they deserve each
other i think they're great for each
other i think they have a lot in common
and i think they should make a show
together called um
hypocrites
maybe uh poses
maybe
any other title for
psych like
julia romeo and julia
yeah romeo and julia
you know and so keemstar obviously has
these these actual absolutely nuclear
takes about mental health that i can't
even show without getting yellowed
because they're so inflammatory insane
but the gist of his takes on mental
health is like people are faking mental
health just to get attention and
sympathy that's his take and trisha goes
uh and she knows all this so she goes on
the podcast right she doesn't she goes
oh keemstar's changed we had a great
conversation this is his tweet
from august 7th
okay
this month a few weeks ago this is a man
who's now enlightened about mental
health he says and this is about me okay
i'm loving this w streak while my
enemies are on antidepressants
going to therapy and gaining so much
weight they are about to lose
their left foot to diabetes stay mad and
fat
what's wrong with being on
antidepressants and going to therapy and
being fat i mean is that really a uh
is that really a uh critique of
someone's character i mean
i mean
i'm on antidepressants
it's like is that really
a valid attack i mean ethan were you
aware that instead of anti-depressants
you could just take a couple sips of
beer yeah
famously it only takes three sips
keemstar famously said nobody should be
taking antidepressants whenever he's sad
he takes three sips of beer and he
cheers right up
so
i ha i have i have tried that it didn't
work for me oh [ __ ]
you just a sad boy and also by the way
going to therapy is a huge l
so anyone who's going to therapy to
better themselves huge l
keemstar believes that you should never
change though so i guess that works for
him but yeah this is the guy who's now
enlightened about mental health issues
tweeting this out literally like one
week ago
text him how was he well i know you're
texting with him tonight trish ask him
how is he doing
trisha went even as far
to defend ryan [ __ ] kavanagh
kavanaugh this guy here hold up
trisha defended ryan kavanagh
this guy here
who according to a judge faked a s a
sexual harassment memo
to fire his cop his ex-co-president to
get out of paying him
and so many other things
he's the guy who's suing us for
copyright infringement he owns triller
uh here's trisha on ryan kavanaugh of
all things like wow girl this person's
suing ethan right now and i get it i i
get it and i'm not
i get it i don't know what i would do if
i was in that situation right but like
sending hate towards someone or
something when there's like a like
it doesn't feel like the right answer
i've never sent hate that way i'm like
i've had to defend myself on that video
what do you call making a hundred videos
about me calling a liar the most vile
per you all you do is send hate that's
your total existence
and by the way
how dare you accuse me of sending hate
to ryan cavanaugh i have only ever dealt
fairly and factually with him
this man behind me ryan cavanaugh who's
suing me for copyright infringement um
i have never sent hate
and i would never
not this man here
ryan cavanaugh kissing harvey weinstein
on the forehead
is it him is that ryan you know which
one it is they don't look that similar
no seriously is it him no it's not it's
the man above i can't tell
i don't know
yeah i mean that's a low blow to defend
ryan
come on
yeah and here's my favorite part
keemstar brought her
dumbass on the show
for 30 minutes and then wrapped it up
and scuttled her away listen to this she
goes that's it i was like yeah that's it
he just used you
enjoy this i'm so sorry that we have to
cut this short but richard
richard has to go but before we go can i
how do you schedule a podcast especially
one that's this big and important and
you don't a lot more than 30 minutes i
mean what i mean
that was a lie right because they they
had gabby hannah come in just a few
hours later we're getting to that yeah
so just to prove to you how willing
tricia is to be used
by keemstar uh he kicks her out and you
guys won't believe what happens next
please comment on these shoes are those
custom yeah they're amazing
is that what that is yeah it's my
chemical romance they look so [ __ ]
cool by the way i i i didn't want to say
i'm comfortable saying this now gerard
way get a restraining order now don't
wait
don't wait for something to happen
because that girl is unhealthily
obsessed with you get a restraining
order gerard away now
don't wait and may i say adam sandler
adam sandler you may want a restraining
order as well that that woman is walking
around in your clothes
that is abnormal behavior
i love those all right that was fast
damn it was quick that was fast damn
maybe we'll have you back on maybe yeah
oh yeah maybe yeah real soon probably
not they don't want to [ __ ] have
anything to do with her we couldn't get
her out of there quick enough yeah 30
minutes you ever heard of a 30 minute
podcast
are you
kidding me so here's the best part
keepstar [ __ ] hates trisha yeah of
course like how could she not see that
girl you walked into such a trap she's
so willing to be used by him
uh the best part okay keemstar ends the
show early
so that he can bring
of all people in the same studio on the
same day gabby hannah
here's a picture as proof
here's now here they are wearing the
same clothing
banks is in the same clothing keemstar
is now wearing george his trademark
jorts because i think he took a swim
we'll get into that too
we'll get into the swim here they are
yeah
banks is in the same outfit and keemstar
just got jorts on
legends legend
yeah
so
um trisha got absolutely played
here now again she's a free speech
advocate all of a sudden and she
believes in uh talking to anyone about
anything right so here is here they
they're kind of teasing her a little bit
they're kind of making a fool out of her
listen to this
explicitly
imagine if gabby was here and we posted
a picture faze banks keebstar trisha
gabby i'd bolt
the internet
she's there gabby's there or at least
she's on her way there so kim starts to
go being like well can you imagine if
gabby was here he's testing the water
i'd bolt
interesting
good
break no you wouldn't do that she's the
only person i wouldn't do that and i
thought you might do that i was like
wait that's weird he's being like too
nice and i was like this is like it felt
awkward
she goes well i wouldn't do that to you
well
you would and you did
well not put them in a picture together
no but like they played her yeah gabby's
literally outside with a freaking
knife
trisha open the door to the exit and
gabby's they're like
um so she got played
big time
also a bonus cringe from keemstar he
posts a picture of him with cersei's
overlooking when she blew up the the
cathedral
keemstar thinks he's cersei he says same
energy
so
you know you want to see evidence that
keemstar hasn't changed since he was 16.
he still says uh he still can't say
picture correctly
here
[Music]
listen to this ethan
catch it what
is this really the right path for you
you've uh you've done i was like
gabby was here
no but listen
imagine if gabby was here and we posted
a picture picture picture
picture of beer i mean that's like romeo
julia all right fair enough uh-huh
see you just admit it you were wrong
i was big of you julia you're saying
i'm putting that on
i'm the saint i can't get it off
i'm stuck
oh really it's
i don't know how
i mad respect to
real monks who dress like this all the
time i don't know how how you do it only
for their only for how they get the robe
on everything else they do
who
cares ethan saying that not me
i'm reading between okay so the next day
i tweeted about
i says listen gabby hannah messaged me
immediately after frenemies broke up
trying to get on the podcast
i knew it would be an interesting show
with lots of views to be had but i
didn't even respond to her and i still
haven't some things you just don't do
and i would never do that to trisha
and so trisha responds to this
revelation
of saying listen i'm a free i'm a free
speech advocate all i care about is
conversation the marketplace of ideas
um i wouldn't care if you talked to
gabby but of course trisha can't keep
track of her own lies because when she
found out that i gabby wanted to come on
the show and i ignored her this is what
she had to say
here
enjoy this
he did show me something i'm not going
to like tell him what to say what it was
i don't want to like
put this on blast but he did show me
something that and he he's like i would
never do that to you like he showed me
something that could have happened that
didn't he told me something that like
would have like devastated me like
really like hurt me really like i would
never do that to you
that meant a lot i almost texted him
just now i'll be just left so i don't be
like that person just texted but anyways
it just meant a lot that like he didn't
end
wow
so she understands the concept
that she would have been devastated if i
had gabby on and that i would never do
that to her she understands that here
for some reason but now when she goes on
keemstar's podcast and circle jerks
about what a piece of [ __ ] i am it's the
hey it's just the marketplace of ideas
here's a great one there's this uh tick
tock account contradictions of trisha
which is like this whoever's operating
is on another level watch this they made
a great summary of the situation
uh yeah have her on
we are in families wrong he did show me
something i'm not gonna like tell what
it was i don't wanna like put this on
blast but he did show me something he's
like i would never do that to you like
he showed me something that could have
happened that didn't do you know what
i'm talking about when he told me that
thing he's like oh maybe you don't know
but he told me something that like would
have like devastated me like really like
hurt me i would never do that to you
that meant a lot i almost talked to him
just now anyways it doesn't matter that
like you know it could have been just
like how many followers is this account
oh my god they're actually well because
holy [ __ ] effer on no th this this bro
whoa this account is banger after banger
i'm actually i have one for later for um
some of these have like uh this one has
2.5 million views
because it
it's actually just that good i mean like
here here i'll just click
was actually planned for my sister's
birthday basically
my mom and moses and that was it ethan
incidentally invited himself to our
family surprise
first of all happy birthday thank you
thank you for inviting me
thank you for inviting me inviting me
on a trip from disneyland a trip that my
mom's sister and moses have planned for
my birthday we did invite ethan and hila
to come willingly and graciously because
i enjoyed spending time with them and
graciously and wanting to we paid for
him ethan and eva did not pay for their
vip ticket to disneyland i begged moses
to let us pay i begged them it's like
who cares you bought me a ticket big
[ __ ] deal i was like what that stuff
was you bought me a ticket you could
just [ __ ] my [ __ ] open mouth then he
didn't even take the time or effort to
watch my sister's video
we didn't buy ethan and then yeah i mean
they're all gold they're the best one
i'm saving for last i want to show you
guys
but anyway
and also she goes oh just talk to gabby
let's not forget that the entire reason
that trisha literally dropped her best
friend shane dawson of many years is
because jeffrey starr went on
his husband's podcast
and she ended the whole friendship with
her best friend of many years just
because of that and i meant to believe
that she wouldn't care if gabby hannah
came on my podcast of course she would
she would have a total breakdown and i
would do i wouldn't do that to her now
or then
here listen to this
this is a screenshot oh no it's a video
okay
there's no audio
alrighty it's reddit it's probably muted
in the corner yeah there we go okay god
on this podcast like a week ago i was
like this is an evil person and what
they said to me is like yeah we have to
slowly distance ourselves and all this
stuff like that and they're like
promoting him still like and and like
shane my best friend should at least
maybe not associated with him publicly
like if you need to get that check from
your palette fine but
this is a person that like was
like literally like i was like suicidal
over and he knew about this and he's
like promoting him and like defending
him and being and like publicly having
him on the podcast for views for your
shitty podcast to have 300 000 views you
can i told him the podcast thing was a
big issue for me a lot take the [ __ ]
dumb podcast down it has three i had 200
000 views at the time that was so tricky
to me i kept saying that he just kept
brushing by like when you know he's an
awful person he's violently told me he's
told you that he thinks he's vile yeah
and then he seem on the podcast not the
least you could have done is like you
know what let's just delete that podcast
it's still up it's like
so
she clearly understands how hurtful this
is she's experienced it herself she's
ended her the friendship with her best
friend of many years because of the same
thing she did to me
so she clearly knows how hurtful it is
so like this whole shtick of her being
like oh i'm just talking to keemstar
it's not ethan's business it's so
synthetic
she goes ethan just playing the victim
because i literally just said it made me
sad
so okay
you know i feel like i've proven my
point that
she know first of all the point is like
she knows what she was doing is her
fault she says jeffrey star's evil what
does that make keemstar she went on his
part you know what i mean
so
the the point is she knows what she did
she knows everything and uh she's
refusing to take accountability for it
and i'm just over it dude i'm over it
i'm just totally over it but here's
something i
saw that actually really disturbed me
uh from this one tick tock account
she's been going on and on
about how
jason and david bought her this dog
and never told her didn't consult with
her just gave her a puppy
and be like here you go bye and she was
talking about how terrible it was that
they did that how she wasn't ready and
it was like insane she said they just
bought me this puppy for a vlog and then
left it there and she's like it's so
insane and i've actually i believed that
she talked about a lot on the show
didn't she
i mean i remember that all the time and
i was always like man that's that's so
crazy
that they bought you this dog and did
that in that way
and i saw this tick tock and it blew
my [ __ ] mind okay just watch this
and then we'll unpack it
my dog was because of david and jason
they just surprised me with it for a
vlog and made me keep it even though i
never asked for a dog and yes we did
talk about this but everyone was like oh
my god you can't surprise me with a
puppy i have been wanting a puppy for a
really long time we had talked about it
for a while that i wanted a pomeranian
that my mom would help me take care of
it just to be clear we did talk about
this and the plan was to maybe give the
dog to
his mom who really wants pomeranian so
i've always said i wanted a pomeranian
but my mom would have to help take care
of it so we're a team effort with this i
wanted a pomeranian for a long time both
me and my mom have wanted a puppy for so
long i live alone my mom was alone was
the color you wanted too right yeah he's
adorable this color is just perfect
everyone who meets them falls in love
with him they just surprised me with it
for our vlog and made me keep it we're
gonna try and get some houses because we
honestly want more we just love this
little guy so so much we just love him
so much and hopefully that'll show in
here we want two more we want a little
black one and possibly a white one i
never asked for a dog go get a dog you
want to go what do you want to buy a dog
today i never asked for a dog
oh my god my dog was because of david
and jason they just surprised me with it
for our vlogging it's so
disturbing to me how she's openly lying
she she really convinced me
of this dog lie and and she really
successfully assassinated their
character now
the thing that jason and david get
criticized for is out there in the
public like the seth kissing prank
and the allegations that were written up
uh about david
but in terms of whatever personal
anecdotes trish is sharing about them
especially about jason and david and
stuff i mean this this specifically has
me questioning everything
and i and i can't help but wonder if
i've just been a useful idiot to her
this whole time
uh at the essay allegation about dom
like all that stuff that was made
publicly separate of her is like you
know
100 believable but like this dog thing
like i just feel like i've been the
useful idiot to her the whole time to
smear these people that she hates
because this is at flat out
horrific lie to make about someone
and so like
and you know if she's willing to
blatantly lie about something so mundane
it really makes me question everything
she's ever said
i mean
mundane
what did i say mandane meandane sure
did you say mandane
you said mandane mundane
[Laughter]
but so and then there's the other point
that she keeps bringing up bring it up
bring it up that i want to address here
now so i could just be done with this
[ __ ] is she keeps talking about the
final episode of frienemies which uh
which you know the last episode the one
that clears her of everything if only
you guys saw this episode you would
understand
so the story with this final episode was
that
it was
it
um
i was feeling bad about how everything
had gone down i was feeling bad about
the rift that it had caused in the
family and everything and and and i
wanted to make amends and in my heart i
thought
what would be great is if we could just
come together for one final episode for
it to be wholesome
for it to be just a beautiful experience
where we just reflect on the nice
experience we have and part ways
amicably
and
as soon as we sat down
basically almost immediately it just
went sideways it just went off the rails
it just turned into more accusations and
it was just got really icky
and i was like immediately regretting it
because it was just
it was just
not at all what i wanted or expected
and honestly it got to a point where i
just really wanted it to end
i was very uncomfortable i was
regretting my decision to have them over
and um
i just got kind of complacent i didn't
want to argue anymore and uh
that was basically it i was like this
this is this is
this is bad
this is not good
and uh
it's it's really not worth uh going up
it's just gonna look it's just gonna
make everything worse
this whole claim that like i had never
apologized to her she keeps saying like
he apologized he i proved that he that
uh
that i never said i wanted to fire the
crew
um you know i admitted in my first video
about trisha leaving frenemies that i i
messed up in showing the crew the text
once again in the first video [ __ ] up
okay
is that i was talking to the crew like
trisha wants to i i was like listen
trisha wants to
hire a new crew i was just being
transparent with them i was like
trisha wants to hire a new crew
obviously that wasn't something i was
going to commit to but i was just like i
don't know what to do about this because
this seems like it's not going to go
anywhere the one that when the crew
found out she wanted to fire them all
so i i i shouldn't have sent the
screenshot to them i i agree i lean on
the crew for a lot of things so like i
usually tell them everything
so her big gotcha moment is that
uh she said she wanted to hire more
people to work on frenemies she had been
bitching about the crew saying they did
a horrible job that the bus tour we did
was horrible that they're super
unprofessional
and i sent that screenshot
to the crew which i should not have done
that was not cool of me to do i admit
and everyone kind of uh
i think there was a misinterpretation
that we're like oh she wants to fire
everyone
and then
uh a lot of the crew was uncomfortable
being like well if she wants to fire us
then
you know it's just weird that we're
gonna go there and pretend like there's
nothing wrong
okay so then when i told trisha it's so
stupid i hate i'm just
she then trisha goes
well um if the crew's uncomfortable then
i [ __ ] quit and i hate them and i
want to fire everybody i'm not
comfortable with all them so she did she
wanted to fire everybody but it was
after the the misunderstanding of her
saying she wanted to hire more people am
i getting that right yes that was
essentially what was discussed on the
podcast and that's that's what i uh i
think the big gotcha that um they that
she
thinks exists in that episode is
but i i don't know why it's a big gotcha
because she wanted explicitly in the
messages she posted our whole
conversation to twitter she's talking
about how she wants to hire new people
and replace the crew so i mean again i
always have said that she didn't
explicitly say she wanted to fire
everyone she basically just set
everything up into and around that
so i don't know
i'm over it regardless
um
you know and i'll be honest there was
another thing aspect to the whole last
episode is that like they secretly
recorded us
which was like
kind of devastating to me
that they came into the house
secretly recorded our conversations
before and after the podcast and during
and have basically been
threat i mean i'm gonna say threatening
but like
the thing is i'm not i don't care if
they release it so it's not like a
threat i think they think i don't know
why they think it's such a big deal it's
just a messy episode
but i guess in their mind they think
they've been threatening us with like
well we recorded it here it is uh we're
gonna release it uh you know i'm
listening to it back it's like
i just found that like
such a violation to come into our house
and seeker they record us i was like wow
i was really blown away by that actually
yeah i remember
i could say who someone said that they
possibly recorded it when you came in
the studio and you said that no they
wouldn't do that to me that's
there's no you i i didn't even consider
it yeah
because i i was like no way they would
come into my house and record and
secretly record like that that's that's
crazy for anyone but they're and i was
like family i was like no no no there's
no way they would do that and sure
enough
you know as soon as uh trisha gets the
first chance she starts she starts being
like uh i was listening back to it
because i recorded it and she tries to
make it sound like well we were all
recording it
it's like not they were secretly
recording us
it's
i was like wow
cause
yeah
so i i honestly don't care if she wants
to release it uh
i'm not going to i i don't think it's a
good idea what i told her about it here
listen you know i'm not gonna i told her
listen this isn't gonna help anybody
this didn't go this went sideways let's
just you know
whatever
i don't know and also if i'm not
mistaken one of your final deciding
factors was the fact that the audience
like they had that reddit up like it was
like four what was like 43 000
upvotes saying that please don't release
the episode just let this
let this go dude it was it wasn't good
for anything it was just it wasn't good
for anything but my my real hope was
that we would have this wholesome
beautiful experience we could mend the
wounds reunite the family and
immediately went sideways and i was just
and immediately i just kind of was
very regretful and just wanting it to
end so i was like you know what whatever
whatever this i'm sorry that i mean the
same thing i apologize for here so i
don't know
i don't know
oh and then so okay so that's the thing
with the secret friend of me is i'm just
[ __ ] putting everything out there i'm
over it
and then so honor a few honorable
mentions
is um
trisha blaming me
for calling tana
out for photoshopping herself watch this
[ __ ]
but trisha was very quick to defend
themselves by saying i never did that
ethan did that not me claiming that they
never called out tana for editing photos
or
anything like that that that was all
ethan calling tana out saying that she
looks like a different person on her
instagram there's so many times where
people think that we like hate each
other or whatever yeah no dude trish is
just brutally honest and if someone's
doing some laughing he's going to call
them out and there are times that trish
has called me up like face tuning
creating a false beauty standard did not
call you out for that i defended you oh
ethan dead no i would have never heard
no she would never i saw she did
something people were calling out for
photoshopping over the weekend and you
know what can i just say i mean she
really does overdo it because i did see
the side by side from this weekend it's
unrecognizable like her face she just
changed her whole face here it is but
like that is like not even her like i
was like
i was so shocked but it's like a
different profile like different
everything it does get a little trisha
is the human embodiment of the kirby
enthusiasm theme song
it basically just plays everywhere she
goes on loop
oh no never heard no no but
i would never
oh and then there's this weird rumor
going around teach i saw there's someone
who reported this someone who made a
tick tock and then everybody reported it
that i liked
uh a tick tock of moses showing the
wounds from when trisha punched him
and i never liked that but here it is i
just want to make that clear that i
never liked that
for whatever tournament
when he's liking those posts like
someone they screenshot it he's liking
those posts
that's really and then throwing it back
in my face all the stuff that i try to
work through because last year drug
induced unmedicated
how about don't make excuses anymore for
your shitty behavior how about that
would you stop
[ __ ] you've been making excuses for
years time to grow up
peace and love
but anyway no i did not like the picture
of moses's bruise on his arm where you
punched him
uh
what she she rosie lee calls it their
altercation
rock bottom 20 20 was my rock bottom on
so many levels up until the december
episode where i did call
a close on that channel names like you
know and it was that was my lowest i
remember i was like wow i'm so
embarrassed and yes that i appreciate
of course i appreciate the fact that he
showed me patience and love of course
and that's why all this hurts and stings
so much because i did appreciate it but
it took him a whole 48 hours to do a
whole hit hold on let me go back to
where she says
that i've addressed
you know about people bringing stuff up
from the past like weaponize it again so
i think it's gross because i think at
the end of the day everyone who does it
has really nasty [ __ ] in their closet
too i've had i've done some nasty [ __ ]
drug induced or not like it's not an
excuse it's out there i've done some
nasty [ __ ] there's an actual show about
everybody i'm commenting on here and now
keemstar there's a here now when people
are like you don't talk about in front
of me because that was stuff that was
happening years ago and i was like you
know what i felt uncomfortable because i
have stuff in my closet in my twitter
that that i've addressed
up until like a year and a half ago the
most disalteration like that's something
that was the altercation
it's awesome
way to whitewash that one
is the darkest skeleton in my it's not
even my closet it's on the open i'll
address it i talk about it even on the
podcast i will i i it's like whatever
that's between them though you know i
mean well what whatever the point is she
blames me for like putting that story
out which i didn't people were already
talking about it she blames me for
liking it on tick tock which i don't
like i literally never bring it up they
made peace together with it and i
respect that and i always have they're
the ones that keep bringing it up and
trying to make it my [ __ ] problems
like look you guys just [ __ ] deal
with your own [ __ ] don't care anymore so
over them
maybe they're mixing up with keem
because keem's the one that always sends
that every time he's in a fight with
trish on twitter oh he does oh yeah all
time that makes sense
he usually just sends me a picture of a
horse to make fun of my beautiful wife
yeah sends me a witch
the irony of course is that our wives
are objectively beautiful women
hell yeah brother and i wonder if uh i
wonder what his girlfriend thinks about
uh
i wonder i wonder what caricature he
would uh compare his girlfriend to we'll
find out in six months yeah well
right
and there's one other thing i do want to
talk about which is this picture this is
the final my final message keemstar in
the pool with his girlfriend he posted
this photo
with a [ __ ] shirt and hat
this guy's such a og dating this 20 year
old girl and he's too
insecure at 40 years old still
to get in a pool without his shirt on
a jersey
how are you not embarrassed to go in a
pool with your shirt on with your girl
that's so humiliating and a hat too
a hat in the pool so frustrated this is
like structures
this picture is amazing this is the
biggest l of all freaking time this was
in the middle of his w's rant on twitter
right and then his own audience tore
them a new one so you got roasted
pretty hard by his own biggest boy
ever dude you swim with a shirt on bro
with your girl big l on my part
what'd she tell you she's not
comfortable with she did she also put a
bag over your head when you guys
i'm not going to say the rest of that
yeah
no
and this speaks for itself
wait what did the tweet say it's below
it i'm literally on vacation and still
winning the internet stay mad
yeah
i think you need to go in a pool without
a shirt on to stay winning and then
after if you scroll down a little bit
more that was his response stop roasting
me for wearing clothes in the pool my
beachbody's not ready yet
game don't be so hard on yourself man yo
it's late august dude the beach body
ain't happening this year maybe next
year i think he's a skinny legend i
actually think he looks great like he's
lost a lot of weight i mean
kudos to him for that i mean he he looks
he looks great i just think it's
hilarious that he's such a
a jersey too it's like
bro i can't
my girl thinks i'm so cool
oh jesus poor keem he's so insecure
actually he's like he's deep down just
such a
he's just a child that wants to be loved
and accepted and so badly and you know
in a way i
i pity him but
you can't excuse the horrible things he
does and says and is as a person
but at the end of the day you know if
you look at serial killers if you
analyze them it all goes back to
childhood trauma and stuff so it's like
you can feel bad for the person you can
pity them as a person but
ultimately serial killers belong in jail
and not because they're a danger to
society i'm not saying obviously that
keemstar is a serial killer but i do
think he's a dangerous society society
and i mean that's made clear by him
going in a pool with a jersey and a hat
on
that ain't normal but that's abnormal
behavior
at 40
any age
i mean i get if you're if you're younger
you're insecure i used to have a giant
mole on my back that was removed but i i
was very insecure about it so i would go
in with a shirt on a shirt but a jersey
i mean unless you're jealous yeah in
like a nelly video from like 2004 you
shouldn't be in the pool but the hat too
it's like are you also wearing sneakers
bro
it's like it just looks like he's fully
clothed
like bro are you wearing shorts and
sneakers it really took me a minute to
like register what was going on in that
picture too because uh
you know at first it just looks like
they're together but then you notice you
know his water line his girl was like
are you sure you want to post this
scroll down
oh oh
what are you looking at just
it's just right out of view where he's
soaked in water from the waist down and
and yeah
perfectly corrupt anyway great it's been
absolutely lovely i love it yeah
i love it
anyway listen i am 100
over
tricia i am tired of her [ __ ] i'm tired
of her lying i'm just i don't want to
talk about her anymore i unfollow her on
all social media i'm done i'm over it
this is the ultimate betrayal i can
tolerate this [ __ ] no longer i'm out i'm
done that's it bye
real quick note about um
speculating about serial killers and
childhood drama and everything
do you know one of the three uh clearest
signs of a serial killer in the making
is fire setting as a child
go on
i don't know if people know this but
when keemstar was a teenager he was
arrested for arson
that's that's like some intel like
where'd you get that one here it was a
deep cut man
go on dan you're going for it okay go on
do you want me to send you the article
from like 2002 or 2003 here
we're here let's just go for it dan
it's in my uh so are we are you
suggesting that keemstar is a serial
killer
i'm not suggesting that but i am
suggesting that in 2006 he was charged
for setting a fire where where'd you
send it to me
here
of all places
it's it's only posted like a few places
on the internet send it to me i'm
pulling it up right now give me yeah
just chill out chill out lovebot keem is
not happy about this one yeah
all right so turns out keemstar was
charged oh the pyrocynical subreddit yes
exactly five years ago wow i did find
this article though but this was yeah
yeah there was actually multiple
articles written about it at the time so
how do we know this is about keemstar
well so it's somebody named daniel m
keane
he was 24 in 2006 matches up with keem's
age it was in arcade new york which is
just outside of buffalo new york okay
and um
i mean let's be real he's [ __ ] keen
okay so let's see police arrest daniel m
keem
24 and his homie dustin
charging them with arson in the fifth
degree and criminal trespassing in the
third degree charges stem after
wellsville police reported seeing smoke
coming from the bathrooms within the
lagoon recreation area
upon further investigations it was
discovered that the two subjects were
lighting fireworks within the bathroom
and caused some damage to the bathroom
after a short foot pursuit
he ran from the police
the two were caught and brought to the
station where they were processed and
held pending their arraignment in the
morning keem as fast as [ __ ] but he
wasn't fast enough that day
not fasting's [ __ ] off boy
interesting
fire i mean fireworks in the bathroom
doesn't seem that bad to be honest i
mean doesn't that seem like something
like you get caught for doing as like a
12 or 13 year old this was 24 4. that's
a little hard well he said you know i
don't like to change
it's true
yeah as a 24 year old and then you're
running from the police i mean that's
pretty amazing
[Music]
i love that there was a short foot chase
like he didn't make it far yep
all right thanks for that dan you're
welcome i appreciate that detective dan
yeah dan had to uh bring out dan the
hater is back
all right guys i've said it all that's
all i've got to say you know uh listen
like i said i'm out i'm done peace and
love
i just don't [ __ ] care anymore all
right
we're back also
uh schedule
after dark tomorrow
and families this weekend that's it mwah
peace and love
[Music]